okay wait to starting basically all we
need is just for a little rain just a
little rain come on come on in the
meantime we just [ __ ] broadcast for
traders because we're probably gonna
[ __ ] die Oh harvest that trap okay
shantanu hydrated okay okay um huncles
dehydrated so things aren't looking too
too good for us right now I guess
Nicholas is fine of course but we're
getting kind of their stay
okay is the cat alive I do not see the
cat so I assume the cat did not make it
dust storm the storm health is going
down the drain respond we could show you
some water water be good do you have
anything else no rope okay keep trying
come on just some right just some rage
just some rain jennifer has damaged a
system Jennifer she [ __ ] left who
will live he'll die
this guy's pretty good so let's have him
fix this let's have him do something
simple like a fuel come on just a little
rain just a low right oh yes yes yes yes
yes looks like we're gonna [ __ ] make
it yeah yeah yeah make it yeah yeah yeah
fix that sleeping bag your [ __ ] ass
so like he walks past that like there's
no work through done hey but you gotta
eat you got any yes yes [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] did we need now we need a rope ah
whoo we got plenty of that here like new
play that [ __ ] I don't need any of this
stuff
ok I hope you have enough water she's ok
we got lots of water now so we have to
continue with our expeditions drink some
water did you suck and take a shower oh
he's cooking he's cooking thank God
what corpse there's a corpse in here JS
s fix it then this groves pretty smart
so I have her scan the frequencies this
lady has to [ __ ] and leave so she has to
[ __ ] dirtiness [ __ ] when we need we need
rope [ __ ]
join is equipped is equipped and this
equipped oh no good
ah [ __ ] it's usually get to give her
some stuff just in case I don't gonna
need this battery the circuit breakers
okay get oh good okay equipped equipped
given these nails just always shut the
trade i guess i think the scanning just
let you know what objects are on the map
how do we have so little water from all
that [ __ ] right hmm
mm-hmm dust storms of [ __ ] durability
output like six people in here once oh
[ __ ] okay fast-forward nothing happening
in two days reservoir yes okay um [ __ ]
this guy should just sleep I guess [ __ ]
we got approached it we're getting
[ __ ] desperate
shut trite oh [ __ ]
all right at least not fight I want to
kill that [ __ ] oh yeah baby yeah search
it
um Shack yep
yes do not need this stuff get in my
face
boo this is good let's take the ship
come on something good Oh [ __ ] rifle
oh [ __ ] some good [ __ ] here mr. lame-o
limestone circuit board [ __ ] hmm who's
that
ah [ __ ] it that's good enough
come on search insertion get involved
definitely get involved oh [ __ ] he have
a gun get your ass over here don't look
around move oh [ __ ] hmm sand don't need
that ticket trade oh [ __ ] i forgot hunka
has like 0 0 what is that friend of a
rainbow yes examine gas mask [ __ ] [ __ ]
all right you guys got a foot get
[ __ ] back here oh [ __ ] broadcast we
need some trades did ooh [ __ ] that's
what I need them [ __ ] uh get rid of
[ __ ] circuit breakers and mannequin
arm scare driver [ __ ]
you
only a 5 1 spot mannequin head I don't
like motors they're so [ __ ] hard to
get Oh forgive me Jesus ok this [ __ ]
better come and come back now keep going
now kick up take on [ __ ] [ __ ] now i'm
gonna add fuel i Jes Christ I kept oh
[ __ ] let her do her [ __ ] it's got your
broadcast for traitors
that guy come back now oh my god no just
come back it oh [ __ ] here we go here we
go whoo we'll take this and this and now
what actually got there what else you
got there nobody [ __ ] items we can go
ooh I need some rubber buck
this is good ok okay oh ok so this [ __ ]
canceled this craft item we need some
[ __ ] snare traps ok go make that can
we upgrade this to make it more
efficient [ __ ] again out leather but
we'll do it as soon as we eat something
harvest this good knack we upgrade this
[ __ ] anymore leather mmm I need a
recycler that'd be nice
transistors and circuit boards is
[ __ ] hard to make spike trap make
another snare trap I guess fix he's not
doing too bad right yep her she needs to
shower but that shit's [ __ ] up I
cindy-lou down Cindy Lou has to go the
bathroom wash it out and she could fix
the other [ __ ] yeah did you got any
water ooh one two three four [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] was that I need a circuit board
still
mmm rubber I don't think I really need
that fuse don't even know what this [ __ ]
is
um sprint it out a little bit
okay she's my to fix this
this [ __ ] can just broadcast I guess
for traders I think it's like the one
salvation thing kind of sucks that
you're just kind of waiting on the rain
because you can't trap oh okay this
right now [ __ ] we are doing good we are
doing good ooh ooh take that set and IRS
that [ __ ] and then fix that it's kinda
like make something um I really want oh
I don't think we need fuel but we do
need a recycler all we need is [ __ ] with
you need plastic plastic and one circuit
board okay we can do that I like afraid
to make something bucket wool and wood
okay they're right there this [ __ ] can
quit doing that go ahead drinks up boom
drinks up and dialing good how this
[ __ ] was going to fix that mmm circuit
board thank you see [ __ ] a rubber now
spring I don't think we really knew that
so the videos we have a lot it is [ __ ]
let's do you [ __ ] what did um now
bucket ah [ __ ] i want to give this guy
some more like [ __ ] I'll every need that
hmm
okay once you drinks water i'm going to
have her clean the [ __ ] shelter no no
she should [ __ ] set up an expedition
q wannabes ooh equipped equipped
equipped and equipped wait I'll go okay
sure I even know it's take you then keep
doing that
ok yes
this guy should probably wake Cindy Lou
should probably wake up add fuel of this
do it twice
yeah yeah yeah yeah how obvious yeah so
I lost your storage limitations [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] out ten at ten that's why
let's see what you got we'll take some
water would take some food guess you can
take on some man okay yes sure she just
took everything I know I didn't do that
where's Cindy Lou [ __ ] how you down now
clean this [ __ ] and then you can get a
slight clear what the [ __ ] in the
clearing
ooh weird stuff garlic bark anti onyx
let's just do food poisoning
no [ __ ] way you gotta be [ __ ]
kidding me oh no no huncle [ __ ] died
wait are you serious bro there's no way
oh my god that is [ __ ] insane all
right I guess we're [ __ ] broadcasting
for recruits cheese s that we have a
circuit board and everything hope we do
the circuit board okay we just need
[ __ ] a robber now
what corpse better go to slight you went
up Attila okay get a slight [ __ ]
oh my god that was [ __ ] up Wow all
right guys looks like I'm gonna have to
end this year with a [ __ ] death that
is [ __ ] up huncle was the man I
trained him to be a warrior that is some
[ __ ] oh all right well sorry had to
see that guy I'm sorry anyways thanks
for watching see you